yeah and you've had like  players that you've coached like get  drafted and and all that man which is  eight well i had eight nine just made it  to the league that i've coached  i have um maybe  about 1500 through college  which is even that's if that might even  be a bigger deal  oh that is a big that's you know 1500  kids yeah just going to college  yeah yeah yeah and i got um  my son my son's like my last coach my  last class of kids is in this  documentary  and it's eight of them and uh  four graduate this year from college and  then  six graduate next year from college  wow talk about that that's crazy yeah  that's mine that's the work i got that's  the crenshaw way